morning it's the day of the oscars and
francesca's here we're getting ready
prepared to get ready for the big day
i've got all my notecards of fashion
things that i need to learn start
studying
i made these last night you're keeping
your hair like that rafting oh yeah just
like this
granny chic but if you watch the getting
ready video you've already seen all this
so
the banana republic sent me like a bunch
of jewelry and stuff to wear for the
event and just was like maybe we can
stick an earring i think we should be
working i think we can turn to the side
oh it's actually really cute i like it i
think this yeah i think you need a
little something something in here i
love it we're doing it oh yeah this is
great
all right so we're about to head over to
the red carpet i couldn't find anything
that
wasn't camo to
cover myself today so i've got this
amazing scarf over top of my beautiful
banana republic gown
but uh
as soon as we get to the carpet i'm
gonna show you guys the full outfit it
looks so pretty i'm so excited and here
we go oh my god i already have coffee
or get this coffee
they took down the tent so the red
carpet right now is honestly drenched
i don't know what's gonna happen but i'm
gonna take you guys with me so here we
go
i just want to sing the fergie song
where she's like gee
l a m
o
r o u s
i wish i had i bet everyone can see my
blood right now i better put this on bye
guys
look how pretty everything looks amazing
lots of people
some people waiting
oh yeah i'm just walking i know where
i'm going where are we supposed to be
going
it's
guys kelly looks so pretty oh my god i
love her dress
all right so the carpet is about to open
so everyone's going to start walking
down
we are about to go live so
i'm excited
with a hollywood amazing cake
my gosh look at this guys
so
guys we just finished our live show
there's been so much michelle you did
such a good job
all right guys that brings it close here
to the red carpet oh my gosh it was so
much fun i'm not gonna lie to you one of
my favorite moments was taking my legos
on the carpet everyone's like oh do you
work for warner brothers i was like
nope
just a fan
so we closed this carpet down it is now
dark they are closing everything
it's crazy
you